tvw dinge präsentiert von der leyen für
oliver länge oder weniger lang weg sind
nico gärtner und mike wittner
auszusuchen das einfache leben mit ihren
kindern wandern sie aus nach costa rica
beatrice und marcel buholzer aus dem
kanton solothurn wurden noch einmal
durchstarten
auf kreta eröffnen sie eine bar von
clarus nach australien familie landolt
möchte mit den ureinwohnern
zusammenarbeiten und betreibt ein ferien
resort in down under
[Musik]
wo sind die kinder keine ahnung das wird
die häufigste frage in den nächsten
tagen sollen
wo sind meine kinder rund 30 stunden ist
es her seit die landolt mit seinen vier
kindern die schweiz verlassen hat das
neue haus der familie ist riesig und
mancher mitbewohner gewöhnungsbedürftig
tochter elena hat einen blutegel
entdeckt brauchst du hilfe man kann ihn
anfassen
er wird versuchen sich fest zu saugen
aber das macht mir nichts
soll ich ihn raus bringen ich bringe ihn
nach draußen ins gras es geht ihm nicht
besonders gut
in der letzten folge räumte familie
landolt ihr sicheres zuhause in glaubens
vater fuhr dort mit den kindern alleine
nach australien um das ferienressort zu
übernehmen
moderieren blieb zurück sechs lange
wochen der trennung vor sich 37 jahre
für andere schaffen damit ist für masse
buchholzer endgültig schluss die frage
was mitnehmen würde bei ihm und ihre
frau tricks zu unstimmigkeiten
nicole gerstner und mike wittner viele
schwer tun zu verlassen
mike hatte den letzten arbeitstag in
seinem laden und tochter jaz elle in
verabschiedete sich im kindergarten in
costa rica angekommen lief erst mal
alles nach plan
dem
es sieht ein wenig aus wie in der
schweiz und ist doch mehr als
zehntausend kilometer entfernt
das neue anwesen der familie landolt 2,4
millionen franken müssen die planer für
das ferienressort mit viel umschwung
aufbringen
eine stattliche summe geld welches die
familie landolt erst noch beschaffen
muss
die aborigines nennen dieses land kann
jamba ort des quellwassers und er machte
zeremonie und das tun wir respektieren
darauf soll die neuankömmlinge schützen
eine alte zeremonie de abrutschen ist
jerry kelly ist stammesoberhaupt für die
familie landolt ist er ein guter freund
aber auch ein geschäftspartner sondern
das lohnt sich eigentlich im märz
begangen wurde
wir sind hier leider hat keiner uni dass
wir begleiteten sind außerdem hört muss
sagen ist das ist auch ganz ausschuss
begrüßungszeremonie und abschluss das
herzlich willkommen sind es wichtig mit
den ureinwohnern wollen die antwort
zusammenarbeiten und kultur programme
anbieten
[Musik]
tag eins im neuen leben von mike nicole
und kindern vor wenigen stunden erst 10
10 san jose gelandet jetzt will die
familie ihren neuen geländewagen abholen
ohne auto kommen sie in costa rica
nirgends hin
haben sie das geld überwiesen nicht so
peschek das hatte ich ihn geschrieben
[Musik]
ich habe ihn mehrmals gesagt dass ich
den wagen zuerst sehen möchte bevor ich
so viel geld bezahlen
wir müssen sehen
der autohändler scheint mit den scheck
ein wenig überfordert zu sein
[Musik]
einen moment bitte kein problem
und dann würde ich gerne warten sie
[Musik]
das autohaus will zuerst prüfen ob marks
scheck über 40.000 dollar gedeckt ist
aber das kann in costa rica tage dauern
das geld ist jedoch nicht das einzige
problem der pick up ist zwar da aber die
wanne und überrollbügel fehlen
ich bin im moment nicht eben glücklich
ganz ehrlich ich hatte ihn schon vor
zwei monaten gesagt war nicht nach costa
rica komme und das auto holen möchte
und jetzt ist es nicht fertig in ihrer
firma scheint nicht zu funktionieren
keine ahnung wie sie hier geschäfte
machen aber wenn in der schweiz ein
kunde zu mir käme und die ware wäre
nicht fertig obwohl ich ihm das
zugesichert hätte dann wäre ja sehr
unzufrieden muss warten bis das autohaus
die fehlenden teile aus den usa bekommt
und ob der händler seinen scheck
akzeptiert ist auch noch unklar
[Musik]
das neue leben von marcel buholzer und
seiner frau tricks beginnt im dunkeln
sie ist in den griechenland angekommen
die beiden katzen kaffee und tee haben
den flug gut überstanden
[Applaus]
im dorf der länder beziehen sie eine
wohnung
sie haben diese unterkunft während ihres
letzten aufenthalts in kreta gemietet
eine spedition hat bereits den gesamten
haushalt der buchholzer in die neue
wohnung gebracht rund 1000 euro pro
monat bezahlen sie für die vier zimmer
tricks wusste genau wie sie ihr nest in
griechenland einrichten möchte einige
dieser möbel hat sie extra noch in der
schweiz gekauft welches aus weil mein
leben ist zerstört dass sie offiziell um
spielmaterial ja auch nur theoretisch
versammelt und bestätigt auch die neue
freundschaften und gesagt was ich mit
der konsument ihre weggemeinschaft sie
hätten überhaupt konnte muss also eine
cannabis versorgen würde es gab für 82
schloss der bewirtschaftung versuchen
sie haben sowieso an bord sein
das neue leben ist nur ungewohnt für
buchholz us und ihre katzen
[Musik]
große veränderungen im leben fordern
große opfer die schulleiterin miriam
landolt wäre gerne in australien bei
ihrer familie
doch sie ist noch sechs wochen an ihren
arbeitsvertrag gebunden
wo findet um mischungen sind sind
natürlich jetzt immer mehr getragen und
zwar bin ich der schuldige rolle als
schulleiter oder und mich plötzlich die
ereignisse nicht extrem genossen jetzt
schon teil von mir wo sie gleich
mitgenommen haben was ich fühle mich so
wäre mir irgendein körperteil
ja
[Musik]
was miriam so vermisst befindet sich am
anderen ende der welt
im ferien resort friday krieg macht sich
ehemann schön an die arbeit
die neuen ferienhäuser hat eine freundin
der familie vorübergehend verwaltet
da find die schlüssel zu allen häusern
und der ist für das australische haus
janet blaney und tschüss frau miriam
kennen sich schon seit über 20 jahren
gut gemacht media ist die zukünftige
besitzerin von freude krieg janet zeigt
wie sie die häuser für gäste vorbereitet
in zukunft wird das familie landet
machen
ich bin in einem die ferienhäuser aber
gleich bei ihnen das war eine junge frau
die hier auf dem gelände heiraten möchte
wir werden sie nun treffen ihre fragen
beantworten und hier die anlage zeigen
damit sie sich ein bild davon machen
kann und schon geht es für schüler als
geschäftsführer los hallo willkommen
auch freude krieg sind sie zum ersten
mal hier
ja so ist es und die eindruck
wunderschön überlässt janet die
besucherin übers gelände zu führen
er sieht sich eher als mann im
hintergrund der sich um die finanzen
kümmern
die rolle der gastgeberin ist für frau
miriam vorgesehen sobald sie hier ist
super jetzt haben damit die trauer ist
nach dem anderen oder ducati zeigen
es ist seine kollegen jetzt erzielt und
damit überhaupt und die vandalen in
cottages mit wirklich harten worte tag
da
[Musik]
auf kreta brichter morgen an bevor nicht
alles am richtigen platz ist fühlt sich
tricks nicht funktioniert sogar bis vor
wenigen tagen ist marcel in der schweiz
noch von termin zu termin gehetzt und
hat im außendienst filtertechnik
verkauft jetzt will er sich in ruhe um
sein herzensprojekt kümmern
eine eigene rock und blues bar
der bus lade
[Musik]
und auch die katze können schon die
gemütlichsten ecken
[Musik]
das würde grob geschätzt
weniger angenehm ist es in costa rica
seit vier tagen schon sitzen nicole mey
conti kinder in der jugendherberge von
san josé fest
der pick up ist immer noch nicht fertig
und in der engen unterkunft hält es die
familie nicht mehr lange aus vater mike
versucht druck auf das autohaus zu
machen
ich probiere noch einmal zu erreichen
ansonsten müssten sie eine weitere nacht
hier bleiben
langsam wird es für mich problematisch
michael ist es nicht gewohnt von anderen
abhängig zu sein
in tunis der selbstständig gewesen und
hat einen eigenen skate und snowboard
laden geführt
hallo herr glory ist wieder mike wittner
ich würde gerne wissen wie weit das auto
ist bitte rufen sie mich so schnell wie
möglich zurück damit ich planen kann
[Musik]
mit dem scheck konnte der autohändler
nichts anfangen
daher hat nike 40.000 dollar überwiesen
seither hat er nichts mehr vom
garagisten gehört
für mike ist klar er bleibt in san jose
bis er den pick-up hat nicole dagegen
hat sich entschieden nicht länger zu
warten
die bilanz mehr und an den ort an dem
die familie zukünftig lebt mit den
beiden kleineren kindern fährt sie in
einem mietwagen voraus hat das nicht
weiß und ich mir dieses
auswandern und gleich getrennt sein so
haben sich mike und nicollier
familienabenteuer nicht vorgestellt
[Musik]
eitel sonnenschein auf kreta
marcel ist in gedanken schon bei seiner
musik war
doch zunächst muss er tricks helfen die
wohnung einzurichten
in einem guten teil der schachteln ist
ein und dasselbe t shirts 150 t shirts
hat marcel mitgenommen ihre sujets
drehen sich alle um rock und blues
berlin bereits diverse bands
was also sind sie für mich große
unterschied ob jemand was man das
theater eine eine sucht ist eine tochter
des mm eine lebensweisheit sowie bleiben
[Musik]
in australien muss das ferienressort
friday krieg so schnell wie möglich geld
einbringen wenn ich die daten eines
gastes vom freitag ansehen möchte klicke
hier drauf janet erklärt das
buchungssystem schule ist zwar
finanzchef einer großen firma aber
leiter einer kleinen ferienanlage zu
sein ist für ihn eine neue welt
großartiger ort um sofort nutzen sondern
sie hat das wirklich süß und zwar sehr
gut konnte es ist eigentlich steht unter
druck
ohne ehefrau mirja muss er das geschäft
übernehmen und auch nach den vier
kindern sehen
der nachwuchs hat das riesige gelände
noch nicht erforscht harry der sich mit
jeanette um das resort gekümmert hat
übernimmt die führung
falls ein ball dort in das rohr in
anholt dürft ihr nicht mit den händen
herausnehmen giftige tiere können sich
auf rainer krieg überall verstecken
ein teil des geländes besteht aus jungen
die dort immer langsam laufen das elend
langsam aber funktioniert hat oder nicht
der wichtigste platz
ähnlich eng genug vom erfolg sondern das
giftigste weil der sommer ist zum
beispiel und die springen
im city nach sopron zunächst im umkreis
von dass plötzlich nick brauns kg stimme
hat wieder spitze wurde zeigen deshalb
habe ich die pflanzen gefunden
auf dem neuen land der familie gibt es
nicht nur harmlose ameisen sondern auch
schlangen spinnen skorpione und anderes
gefährliches getier tochter maria hat es
erwischt
mehrere blutegel haben sich an ihr
festgesaugt wo haben sie dich gebissen
im schuh gib mir deinen fuß
das war's
[Musik]
so sollen kleinere
polizeikontrolle
das ist blöd aber es hat im inline
skater und blöd jetzt kurz macht aber es
ist die erste bewährungsprobe ist
überstanden
[Musik]
in costa rica sind nicole und die kinder
noch drei stunden von ihrem neuen
zuhause entfernt
mit der fähre geht es zur halbinsel
nicole im surfer-paradies costa ricas
dort haben nicole und mike zwei kleine
ferienhaus gemietet
später wollen sie selber ein grundstück
kaufen und bungalows bauen
[Musik]
ja
fast schon ferienstimmung selbst der
putzmann sprüht vor lebensfreude mit
wenig zufrieden zu sein
das gefällt nicole
[Musik]
hätten wir noch um welchen ort das handy
nicht um hier nach draußen wo meist
kleine buch zu machen
[Musik]
ihren traum ist nicole schon ganz nah
mai konsum show würden ihr gerne bald
folgen
[Musik]
wie weit sind sie mit dem auto ist es
fertig
dann kann ich es jetzt sehen das wäre
großartig zumindest ein problem scheint
gelöst
die 40.000 dollar aber sind noch nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
morgen wird das geld endlich beim
händler ankommen dann sehen wir uns
hoffentlich morgen
[Musik]
den ganzen tag haben marcel und tricks
kisten versäumt endlich haben sie zeit
für einander in können kreta in der vor
saison genießen haben sie keinen fisch
[Musik]
in aion nicolo einem touristenort ein
paar kilometer weiter wurden marcel und
tricks ihre rock und blues bar eröffnen
masse kann es nicht schnell genug gehen
tricks möchte sich zeit lassen um ein
passendes lokal zu finden am liebsten
ein ganzes jahr
was war die welt zum besten
das war gedeckt also sage ich mal bist
du hier bist du darfst du hingehörst das
würde aber das tor nicht so gut wenn
eine person arabischen solches
verbrechen das braucht natürlich umso
mehr hat mit umso mehr
ja das war schon gut
als pionier
dann müssen wir fragen
die beiden sprechen kaum ein wort
griechisch sie sind auf die hilfe einer
maklerin angewiesen die wir sie die
verhandlungen führt
wann wir zählen
dass musik doch nicht jeder millionär
wurden und werden die monat des euros
für dich liebe medien und qualität in
sechs wochen beginnt die saison für
buchholzer sehr ruhiger zweisamkeit oder
mit vollgas in der bar
[Musik]
nicole ist endlich in santa teresa
das dorf können die kinder bereits sie
haben hier ihre sommerferien verbracht
[Musik]
in einer bäckerei ist nicole mit einer
freundin aus thun verabredet ania reist
drei monate durch costa rica sie hilft
nicole beim start in der neuen heimat
[Musik]
zusammen warten sie auf den
hausverwalter er bringt nicole und die
kinder zu ihren bungalows die sie ohne
ihn nicht finden werden
die beiden häuser haben nicole und bike
im internet gefunden und für drei monate
gemietet 3000 dollar haben sie dafür
bereits im voraus bezahlt
jetzt da nicole die unterkunft zum
ersten mal in realität sieht macht sich
ernüchterung breit
zu sagen
gibt es hier nicht
das ist momentan nicht angeschlossen was
nicole vorher auch nicht wusste die
bungalows liegen außerhalb des dorfes
mitten im dschungel
es gibt nur ein kleines problem ich kann
den schlüssel nicht finden
aber morgen bringe ich heißt es mit dem
licht das licht mache ich später bruder
wieder das volle leben flotte sprüche
können nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass
die beiden häuser nicht eben
paradiesisch sind
[Musik]
gleichzeitig hätten die macher
ausgelastet
[Musik]
extrem ab
hier spricht mit mutter miriam die
blutegel beschäftigen sie immer noch
[Musik]
nebenan telefoniert vater schön mit dem
verkäufer der liegenschaft 2,4 millionen
franken müssen londons aufbringen
ein großer teil davon fehlt immer noch
und bald läuft die zahlungsfrist ab es
sieht gut aus
sogar sehr gut wir tun unser bestes um
den termin für die zahlung zu halten so
wie es aussieht haben wir geldgeber aus
der schweiz
für sie wäre es besser wenn wir so
schnell wie möglich bezahlen
das wissen wir schon setzt darauf
investoren in der schweiz zu finden als
finanzspezialist hatte ein gutes
netzwerk aber bis jetzt hat er nur vage
zu sein
sie sind einfach die schweizer zusammen
aus der schweiz finanzieren und das ist
ganz wichtige spieler also mir können
jetzt natürlich cs schweiz gestohlen
das sie braucht lohnt sich das immer
noch mit schweizer investoren zu machen
die auch draußen ist oder wie man nach
telefonaten ist abermals und der fahrt
immer bis über acht prozent
das ist abstrus unter diesen bedingungen
ist für das projekt gefährdet
[Musik]
costa rica die nacht im dschungel ist
überstanden doch selbst schönes wetter
macht die häuser nicht wirklich charmant
und platzwunde wunderschön und zu schaut
immer noch nicht wirklich grundgedanke
hochgefahren worden
der falschen artikel wieder zugeschlagen
wird übel uns gerade in solchen mit
woche der lounge paris wird die nie weiß
nicht wie ich das land
und in der nächsten woche bei auf und
davon
mike und nicole packen bereits wieder
überraschung auf kreta marcel bekommt
das angebot für eine bar schneller als
erwartet
[Musik]
tricks ist darüber alles andere als
glücklich
miriam kommt endlich nach australien und
legt gleich mit der arbeit los fiel
hingegen muss zurück in die schweiz
er sorgt dafür dass für ihre ferien
resort weiter geld reinkommt
[Musik]
tel aviv
ruby will
[Musik]
und davos präsentiert wurde der leyen
für oliver längert oder weniger lang weg
sind